hello everyone and welcome back to the
road 2000 as always my name is caleb
dunby and i will be your driver on this
journey
um tonight i was just chatting with our
in-person audience here uh we're gonna
be talking about a special event the
meltwater champions chess tour finals so
this is the concluding event of the
champions chess tour that's been hosted
by the website chess24
along with magnus carlson world champion
uh and we were talking about the rise of
online events there didn't used to be
many of these before the coveted 19
pandemic there were some chess.com had
some events but uh these days they are
very very commonplace and i don't see uh
these online tours ending anytime soon
uh it's just so convenient for the
players to be able to play from anywhere
and for
uh there to be really a lot less
overhead you know you don't have to rent
out an entire hotel anymore to host a
chess tournament you can just have
everybody get a computer
um but the player i wanted to focus on
today is actually levon aronian because
he
is playing from the st louis chess club
uh and so i've had the pleasure of
actually proctoring some of his games
and so i've gotten an up-close view of
what these games have been like live in
person
and so i wanted to talk about them see
if i could share some insight uh into
these games
so to start with i want to look at games
from today uh when levon ironian was
playing against aneesh geary uh it was a
good day for the lavon and as you can
see he actually won uh at least one or
two of these games against denise so
let's just uh get into it here
in this game lavon had white
and this was actually the second game
they played uh geary got off to an early
lead winning the the first game of the
day against lavon they play four games
in a day so lavon needs to come back uh
come back rather strong uh so to do so
he plays e4
now geary was up for a fight he plays c5
going into the sicilian
we get knight f3 d6 d4 the open
open sicilian knight f6
knight c3
and now a6 so we are in the night orf
and now
levon aronian plays the move f3 so
uh not quite a sideline but you know not
not the hordes of theory that you're
gonna get into with bishop g5 and the in
in that main line or in bishop e3 in the
english attack
but not yet not quite the the quieter
lines like bishop e2 either just just
going on with f3
black now decides to expand with e5 uh
in the classical nidorf idea of course
it's not too late to go e6 and transpose
into some of these variations but e5 is
the main point in the night or that's
what black chooses here we get knight p3
bishop e6 bishop e3 both sides just
getting their development out there
and black plays an early h5 um so i
wanted to at least briefly mention this
idea i talked about a little bit in my
series on the night or but
why is black playing h5 so early
open question to the audience
yeah that's exactly right um it's hoping
to prevent any kind of early expansion
on the on the king's side
uh now there are a couple downsides to
this move though
the one obvious downside is that it
costs time uh you have to spend time to
play h5 time you could spend developing
uh but what else could potentially be
the problem with this h5 move
forfeiting a future
on that side
um yeah so not necessarily forfeiting it
entirely but it makes uh castling king's
side more risky is what you're saying
right uh because as we all know whenever
you push a pawn forward uh on the side
where potentially your king is going to
be it can be used as a hook it's
something that the opponent can latch on
to it's actually going to make moves
like uh g4 scarier if you're if you're
castled because then already white is
threatening to open things up
and then there's one last downside to h5
that that's worth mentioning that i want
to just point out
uh yeah you were saying white can pin
the knight but uh just at its core the
g5 square is going to be a lot weaker
um and it's actually this h5 move that
is going to decide a lot in this game so
pay attention to how levon is is using
this move to to influence kind of his
play
and what a niche is doing differently
uh compared to normal because of this h5
move so
to start with uh lavon chooses this line
with knight d5 which is just one of the
main options here
and this is going to change the
structure so
now because we've played h5 moves like
bishop g5 as you said are going to be a
bigger problem so black's not really
going to let this sit
you could theoretically play knight b to
d7 but uh no reason to let this knight
stand on d5 so black captures this time
with the bishop
um i don't think you want to take with
the knight here this bishop is going to
get kicked around and it's kind of in
the way of the the knight on b8 as well
so we get bishop takes pawn takes now
knight b to d7
queen to d2
and g6 from anish geary so so far so
normal
and here rather than go for bishop e2
lavon chooses to castle queenside so
we're still in very well trodden
territory here so i want to put two more
moves on the board bishop g7 by anish is
uh not the most common more common is
just attacking this pawn directly and
this move leads to just some
simplifications but anish wants uh once
more so he plays bishop g7
um so why come to g7 is the question so
uh what's what's the alternative are you
saying why not go to e7 why not uh
that's too smart for me but just why do
g7 at all in other words i don't see any
tactical advantage to it all it does is
it's not even freeing up the back row it
can get you ready to castle but it's
already weak on that side because of the
pawn structure yeah um
so there's a couple reasons to to put
the bishop on g7 uh you don't seem
thrilled about the idea of castling but
castling is going to be a really
important idea in in the position
um and it's good to have it as an option
now uh g7 is definitely a better square
than e7 here i'm going to claim
uh because from g7 the bishop does
actually have some some latent potential
so there's a very important break in the
position that black is always going to
be considering uh and that break is e4
so this is what black uh is is thinking
about this is the advantage to taking on
d5 as well
and you're saying no is not for the next
move it's where three moves down yes
some sunny day black might be able to
play this move e4 and uh just just to
play some bad moves you can imagine like
something like takes takes queen moves
the knight jumps in and now we see our
bishop is is going to be working well
here to support to to support some queen
side attacks
yeah
so uh king b1 comes on the board from
white and this perhaps uh points out
another advantage to keeping the bishop
over here
is if white were to get a little bit too
ambitious and move some pieces off this
bishop might even consider coming out to
this diagonal as well
just another reason to choose g7 over e7
so king b1 is a nice improving move and
then here we see anish uh take uh the
game into uncharted waters so
i wanted to pause here and ask you guys
how you want to finish development for
black there's really two
two paths you can take
and we'll see that denise chose
one that's maybe not not so good
yeah and that's that's pretty much uh
the two main ideas here so
uh
along with castle and king's side where
are you going to put the k put the queen
just as a follow-up
c7
right so something like queen c7 and
then and just just
continue a few more moves uh ignore
what's what white is going to be doing
but what is like black's ideal setup
here
yeah rook fc8 probably right
um yeah so you're putting pressure down
the c file right this is kind of black's
ideal setup this is
of course the castle king side you bring
the queen you bring the rook from the
king side into the attack and then you
start throwing pawns at them right this
this seems like a normal idea
uh but in practice we can actually check
the database and we see that there are a
number of games here
and it's it's always a good idea when
you're analyzing these games to to take
a look at where they deviated and uh
look at look at some games that that uh
follow a similar vein so i want to look
at what happened when black followed
this most natural plant so to do that
we're going to switch over to another
game played by anish geary uh this time
it was against lenie dominguez and we'll
see that you know maybe this is why
anish chooses the other plan of rook c8
just going directly for the queen slide
without castling without bringing this
h8 rook into the game uh this is what
anish chooses to do against levant
and to understand that let's look at
what anish played against lenier so he
chose instead to play this move queen c7
now uh lenie chose the natural bishop e2
connecting the rooks and preparing for
g4
and so aneesh castles king's side we do
see this early g4 by uh lenier dominguez
in this case now rook fc8 white simply
goes rook c1 to help defend the king
takes on g4 takes on g4
and then black pushes on the queen side
but white pushes on the king's side and
we can see that after a4
takes
um takes
now this knight is actually uh kind of
traps you could in theory play knight a1
but that's not the best so instead
lenier continues pushing black regains
the peace but at the end of the day uh
it's white's attack that turns out to be
more powerful we see the bishops
pointing towards the king's side and in
the meantime
uh black wasn't able to do able to do
enough on the queen's side lenny
actually had this nice rook sacrifice
and here here white is just winning so i
don't want to get bogged down in the
details of this game because that's not
the focus of our lecture
but uh lenie does go on to win this game
with this nice attack now
queen for the two rooks but a lot of
pawns on the queen side and uh and
lenier goes on to win this is from the
world rapid championship in 2019 if
you're curious
so perhaps anish has some bad memories
uh in this line and you know having
played queen c7 and castle's king's side
it turns out in practice white's play on
the king's side was just a little bit
more active
uh and again that comes back to this h5
move if you're going to castle kingside
with h5 on the board g4 is going to be a
really powerful idea
uh so in this case anish chooses rook c8
so
we talked more about this other plan of
queen c7 castling kingside and launching
the attack
but what's going on with rook c8 what is
what is black's plan for development now
how is it i don't understand because he
can't get his uh his knights are
completely pinned down they have no room
to develop because it's because i don't
see b6 is really a development
um there's nowhere else to go for the
knights
i
this is where it just just confuses me
where i don't understand
at this point in game the difference
between me and the grand master because
i would have no idea what to do and they
obviously do
the only thing i can think of that's
obvious to me is to pin the knight
against the queen
with a bishop out from white and that's
the only thing i can think of
oh well um
for black to move right now yeah so
honestly no idea because that is c
because uh c2 is completely defended
so there's no point on to put the queen
on the c file
so yeah fro from black's perspective um
this this sort of seems like a not as
strong of an idea on the queen side and
the reason for that uh like you're
saying is we don't have a uh the most
pressure we we could have on c2 although
just just to point out uh if we do play
some slow moves here
uh there is a threat with c2 which is
where we're trying to overwork some
pieces here and again keeping our eye on
on e4 with some sacrifices and some
attacking
that ideas up on the g3 that's pointless
well you're still looking for for
trouble here um so it's mixing these
ideas it's good to have this pressure
even if you're not making an immediate
threat because it it sort of locks down
some white pieces
um so black is still going for the same
type of queen side play that we saw
before the difference is now he gets to
keep his king in the center that's
actually the advantage to playing like
this because g4 is not going to be as
powerful our rook is still here to
make use of an open h file
but the downside is with this rook still
on the king side you're sort of playing
down a major piece on the queen side in
that other game we saw this rook from h8
swing over to c8 and help in the attack
um now in that game
white was also able to get play on the
king's side which is why black ran into
trouble but you black at least had this
counter play on the queen's side now
here black's going to be going for
similar ideas but uh just without this
extra rook
so how is this going to impact
lavon's plans well we'll see in a moment
so first he plays this move h4
so how do you guys feel about uh about
h4
he's attacking he's precluding
uh castling
from black
it seems like he's throwing pieces
getting ready for an effective attack
anything yeah that region because is his
queen size queen-size castle is
forfeited now it is forbidden you can't
do it now
right well black black is signaling that
he's he's going to keep this king in the
center right so oh he's going to keep it
at least for the moment yeah so to me it
likes black has like white has an
overwhelming advantage with that simple
move because you get to start attacking
the center
and developing the pawn chains is that
incorrect well that's the thing is i
think this move is is a little bit uh
tricky because you know when you think
of h4 you think of okay you're launching
an attack on on the king's side and
there's definitely still potential for
that with bishop b2 and g4
but i think this move is actually
more uh
controlling and prophylactic than it is
attacking it's locking down the g5
square and just cementing uh white's
grip on these sorts of weak squares
making sure that black really can't do
anything himself on the king's side
and the reason for that is because we
see that after anish plays this next
move knight to b6
lavon is now going to shift his focus
so uh since black has delayed castling
has avoided castling for so long
um lavon is going to say that there's
not as much point in attacking on the
king's side instead he uses this nice
move h4 to lock down the king's side and
switch his focus to the queen side where
black does not have nearly as much
control
because he's delayed castling because
he's left this work over here his
position is weaker on the queen side and
so now we see levon is switching to that
side of the board so with that in mind
what move uh sticks out here it's
actually kind of a
uh for white it's kind of forced in this
position
um well okay
not forced but trade
that would be um that would be the other
choice uh but we we really don't want to
give up this bishop for this night just
yet okay
uh
the other day
and
then i can't see anything else
yeah so queen a5 is is
is the move um and the idea here is that
of course well number one we're
defending our pawn
um and number two we are again moving
our pieces over to the queen side
um okay number three we're also making a
threat but that's that's a little a
little more beside the point uh
so the uh move you have to look out for
when you play queen a5 is of course this
uh not queen
not queen to c7 but this idea of knight
to c4
um
so
we'll we'll we'll see it in a moment so
let's say queen queen c7 c3 is lavon's
choice to defend his king
we need this rook here to defend the
d-pawn so rook c1 is not an option as it
was in the previous game
and now we see uh black coming out with
knight c4
so obviously lavon anticipated this so
what do we think his idea was
um against against this knight c4
so a4 you might run into
b5
and it's
i mean i'm not even saying that this is
uh
this is bad for white it gets a little
bit complicated but i think uh
i think we can do better maybe just king
f8 here black is gonna have the extra
piece and you still have some problems
um i mean there's
i wouldn't say it's it's obvious but uh
once you see it and understand why it's
good then uh
it becomes very very logical it's
there's a logical move here i won't say
it's obvious but it is logical
well we've got problems right we've got
takes knight here
but instead
bishop takes knights here
um
and the reason is
okay well we trade the queens first and
then bishop takes knight
um and the reason is
uh again this game is is sort of all
about the weak squares he plays h4 to
clamp down
on the weak dark squares on the king's
side and then he makes this trade of of
the queens and of the bishop for the
night to weaken the dark squares on the
queen side as well of course we traded
our light squared bishop uh which cannot
attack the dark squares for the knight
on c4 which of course was attacking all
the dark squares
um and because of that lavon now sort of
gets a total grip on the position and
it doesn't look like white should have
much an advantage uh here i mean it
seems like black's position should be
just fine
but after the next two moves it really
just turns into uh
into a total clamp so let's see if you
can find him
even if black castles we're gonna see
that lavon has has a total grip on
things here
yeah so knight a5 this is this is the
key move uh knight a5 now making use of
these dark squares
and this is an idea that um if you've
ever listened to our commentary you'll
hear maurice ashley talk about it all
the time his favorite trade in chess is
bishop takes knight
because the play that follows uh is is
really always uh logical like this you
start invading the color of squares
of uh
that of the
other color from the bishop you gave up
so we gave up the light squared bishop
so now we invade on the dark squares we
strengthened our dark square control by
giving up this bishop so we we have to
make use of them now
so knight a5 comes in hitting the rook
hitting the hitting the pawn the rook
comes back to c7 and we just follow in
with bishop b6 now the rook has to come
over to d7
and the problem here for black is lavon
all those turns ago has locked the
position down on the king side another
downside to h5 is it weakens our control
of g5
that's relevant not only for the pieces
but for ideas of playing a pawn break as
well
we've locked things down on the queen
side using our dark square control we're
pressuring a weakness here as well
and black is sort of left without a good
plan here
and in the meantime white definitely
does have a useful plan and if you're
familiar with these structures i think
you'll be able to find it
so black without a useful plan white
with a useful plan and because of that
white is going to be significantly
better here
so before i go on who knows what that
plan actually is for white in this
position
what's the plan
to get onto the bathroom
oh we have problems no just a slight
adjustment
is
um not necessarily the the back rank um
in this case
we
yeah uh i'll let you think for a little
longer before i give anything away
ah we had to shut the wi-fi off use the
ethernets
i feel like the
d6 pawn is pretty weak
i don't know
if we could get enough pieces there to
take it down i'm also thinking of
centralizing the
h pawn of the h rook rather i'm gonna
put it on
yeah
so yeah okay rookie one is is a really
good move in fact i think that's what
lavon played no okay he plays a
different move first but uh
that makes sense
yeah rookie one is is a good move uh not
only because black isn't black's
probably castling now he's not so
worried about getting checkmated with
queens off the board but if black does
have an active idea it's to play e4 that
that's all black has left really
um so rookie wants a good move but long
term uh white has a very
strong
uh plan to give black a lot of problems
and uh opening up to the to the youtube
chat i don't think i see the answer in
there either
um so we'll we'll see levon's next move
and see if this gives you any ideas
so so not g4 but actually we're going to
go c4 and we're going to go b4 c5 and
try to make a past pawn out of our d
pawn
so you were on the right track thinking
about this uh backwards d6 pawn we're
not going to be able to put enough
pressure on it with our pieces but by
launching our pawns forward this type of
pawn storm is what's going to to give
lavon the advantage here
um so c4 super strong move
uh black does castle and then as you
said rookie one is a very good improving
move uh you just want to control the e4
square a little bit more and prepare for
for black's opening up at the position
uh and now there's no time to waste uh
rookie 8
king c2 we're activating and
again black has no ideas other than to
play e4 so e4 lands on the board
question yeah um
bishop and knight on amv fellow are now
useless they're not doing anything
whereas they were super important before
you castled
so isn't that a huge disadvantage for
lebanon um so that's not the case at all
they're actually hugely important in our
plan uh the bishop helps support c5 the
knights uh is actually pressuring the
b7 pawn
and at a later date it will be useful in
helping for a c6 push if if we get that
far
and so it's attacking a weakness it's
controlling all of these uh important
squares and it's aiding our plan so so
those
pieces immediately well defended and
you're saying that's immaterial because
in a while they're gonna be going pushed
and you can advance the attack yeah um
you know all it takes is a couple moves
and and we'll see how important these
pieces are um
uh and for the moment it's
this knight is tying down a rook uh and
whenever you're kind of tying down a
piece of a higher value like that it's
it's usually
serving an important person
but yeah this bishop especially and
aside from that it sometimes it's enough
just that your pieces are safe um these
pieces are so solid over here on the
queen side they can't be kicked away by
pawns they can't really even be attacked
by their their counterparts from the
black side
and uh because they're so solid that
gives white this freedom to just launch
these pawns forward they're safe and
they're
future threats
so even though they don't seem to be
activated by traditional analysis
they're ready to kill yeah right
they're useful they're not making
tactical threats but they're useful
where they stand so e4 from black we're
actually just going to ignore it and
play uh b4
and the reason why we ignore it here is
because this pawn on f3 does a great job
of keeping this knight at bay and if we
take that goes away whereas if we leave
our pawn on f3
um black is going to be facing all the
same problems here with this knight just
being unable to move
so in the game okay this this actually
does happen uh and we threw in a rook
takes e8 uh trade first so it takes
takes back on f3 now
bishop f6 is putting pressure on to h4
um now the thing is
lavon says i don't care he just plays c5
and now we start to see
these pieces are sort of making a
pathway
down the board for for the c pawn
uh
we get d take c
from anish giri it's
this trade is is mainly just to activate
this rook try and get some counter
threats in the center
b takes c bishop takes h4
and now pawn to d6
uh so the upside for white is we got
these super strong pawns so far advanced
down the board and black actually did
manage to pick up our h pawn over here
so white now has the activity has the
freedom to move this rook around move
these pieces around as well black's
pieces are going to be a little bit more
stuck defending but black now has an
extra pawn
so white's position
uh just just to spoil it a little bit is
going to be really really good here it
turns out this extra pawn isn't as
meaningful as as these super strong
pawns here and we'll see why in a little
bit
so king h7
now like you were saying um
these pieces maybe
could be improved they have served their
purpose by supporting our pawn push down
the board and keeping things locked on
the uh the queen side but now how can we
improve them further talking about our
nightmare bishop
uh the knight is now not doing anything
the bishop is intimately connected with
that pathway
i have no idea where to move the knight
that's going to make it more relevant
well what's stopping us from making a
queen
uh
from getting to see
from either d8 or c8 right now since we
played d6 it looks like we're more
focused on this pawn because now c6 it
can always be taken
away and you got a knight on it yeah so
so this rook's in the way our bishop
controls the queening square so can we
use our
knights to take to take b7
oh okay maybe not that's uh drastic and
not just one move ahead just long-term
plans white can afford to play a little
bit more slowly here because black is so
tied
uh down ahead and advance on a c file
to give up that now
uh well okay c6 is it's going to be
taken and i think our d-pawn is going to
be weakened by that our c5 pawn is
important to to maintain our grip
i have no idea anybody
help me yeah don't be afraid to move
backwards sometimes
so i mean both of these moves i count as
backwards so knight c4 i think is is
actually a bit better now um getting the
e5 is going to be a little bit hard like
what if uh bishop g3 for example so what
what's our actual next destination for
the night
it's it's a really uh
i don't know i think it's a really
beautiful reorganization of the white
pieces here
i'm sorry two um
yeah
e3
okay not not that far back not that far
back
but uh we can actually see the knight in
the bishop transpose places here and
become
become even more powerful in their own
right so this knight's actually heading
for b6 to help uh harass this rook a
little bit
and okay i put some moves on the board i
think they were the game moves yeah they
were
um
and so yeah lavon just goes knight c4 uh
heading for e5 as you said uh bishop g3
and then this this beautiful move bishop
a5 so two retreating moves but they
actually activate the white pieces so
much now knight b6 is always going to be
a threat and this bishop can can even
think about coming back to c3 if it
needs to put some pressure against the
the black king for any reason
um so two really really beautiful moves
there uh h4
knight b6 hits the rook
comes back to d8 and lavon uh puts this
knight onto d5 now uh
activating this bishop again
uh rook back to d7
and then there was some shuffling
involved here but uh okay f4
is a nice and natural move by lavon it's
keeping this g6 pawn from joining its
its partner here on h4 to support its
advancement
um and by the way just look at this
knight compared to this knight just
uh locking this guy on on the back row
so f4 black does
play this move g5 anyways
if you don't play g5 you play
it okay well if you don't play g5 the
question becomes what move do you play
um your rook can't move your knight
can't actually move otherwise i have
knight f6 with chuck if your king moves
my bishop might again start giving you
some problems
um and that's that's kind of it you're
running out of moves h3 is bad
immediately because of rook d3 picking
up uh okay well wait no there's there's
h2 here so
okay
h3 there must be something wrong with it
but uh
i couldn't tell you offhand all right
i'm gonna cheat because
these positions are too complicated to
think about okay just direct h1
and if h2
we bring our king over and take this guy
okay
so h3 immediately not so good as well
although perhaps that that would be my
choice instead we get g5 by geary which
is it's a it's a sacrifice but it gets
this f pawn out of the way and lets this
bishop kind of come back to to help
uh keep these pawns at bay
all right um okay first lavon though
plays knight b6 again and knight c4
and now takes on g5 and
as for the the mystical backs back and
forth with the knight i think the answer
is this is a rapid game and lavon wanted
to gain some time on the clock so he's
he's not losing anything by playing
these moves so he inserts them um
what is the initial time oh my goodness
uh i know they have a 10 second
increment and here i can actually just
check right
okay no it's it's game in 15 with a 10
second increment
um no it's it's useful info happy to go
over it
um so f takes g5 letting the bishop back
in and now uh h3
and the knight dances one more time to
get 20 seconds on the clock
uh and now king d3 so this is the last
step in in white's play here is this
rook supports the pawns and stops the h
pawn the knight and the bishop are as
improved as they can be
and so now lavon is is ready to come
with the king as well to
either
take this guy on h3 or to help support
the the center in some way
so h2 is played the knight dances one
more time
now king e2
king
f3
and now rook h1 the king drove away the
bishop and we can pick up uh black's
only active idea which was pushing this
h pawn the ship takes rook takes
and now things are going to fall very
very quickly our rook is no longer
hampered by this h pawn so levon is able
to invade
and once again use the pieces
finally to push through with d7 now that
we have this extra support from our rook
on h8
uh f5 was played and now levon just
queens
and wins the bishop and then uh
you know because he's lavon ironian he
can very very easily win with an extra
knights or an extra bishop in this case
when's this pawn
in the game
yeah so i mean it's
you know winning a piece is enough uh so
we're happy to give up our queening pawn
for an extra piece to to win in the end
game and so here anish geary actually
resigns
uh believe it or not black is is
probably getting checkmated here just to
play a simpler move like let's say this
i'm gonna go knights f6
and this is a difficult idea to stop if
you go rook h2
come in with my king
and checkmate is is still gonna happen
so believe it or not white's not even
queening with the black king in the
corner it's it's kind of just checkmate
and that'll do it
so
yeah if you understand this whole game
you might get to might even get further
than that
but uh some really useful ideas to to
take away here so
it comes down to this move uh h5 first
of all and then rook c8 was the really
uh committing move
by giri and once lavon sees this move
rook c8 uh you see him really switch
plants he he goes away from the normal
ideas of bishop e2 g4 things like this
attacking on the king's side and he
leans towards this move
first h4 to lock down the king's side
and then after knight b6 especially
queen a5 fully committing to locking
things down on the queen side and
playing on this side of the board
and the the lesson that you can take
away from this is well yes the specific
idea in the najdorf but more broadly
than that
if you understand your opening well and
you understand the normal ideas
then you are much more well equipped to
handle deviations right rook c8 is a
deviation from the normal plan and lavon
understands okay the normal plan black
is attacking on the queen side with two
rooks so now that black is going to be
missing one of those rooks maybe i
should play on this side of the board
and that's how you can start to punish
your opponent for uh deviating from from
the normal lines in your openings you
understand
hey they're missing something that they
should have on this side of the board
maybe that's where i should uh
divert my my focus
and because of that lavon
plays some very accurate moves
uh finds this idea of giving up the
light squared bishop for the knights and
then is able to get this fantastic grip
on the position with these two minor
pieces after that it's as simple as
pushing the pawns
and then uh
you know uh
having the perfect technique is a part
that's uh is always going to be
difficult but levon ironian had it to be
geary in this game so any questions on
this game now
so
a couple rules in chess
about for when we are teaching beginners
or even intermediate students is correct
and he's progressing for this control of
the cmd file
toward eventual domination of the board
yeah this is a very very useful piece um
of course uh what you were saying is we
teach beginners knight on the rim is dim
uh and that's because it can only move
to four measly little squares compared
to a knight in the center which could
you know move to eights but the fact of
the matter is uh these three squares are
really really important uh in this
position so every rule in chess has
exceptions um and
by the way in a site about this
particular rule this one is is actually
not so popular uh with uh super strong
players i think there's
a famous quote i could not tell you by
who i never remember who says these
things but there's a famous quote that
said uh this is the worst rule in all of
chess like this is the least true rule
that that is still being taught
um and i mean in a sense
it is the least true rule because there
are tons and tons of positions where a
knight on the rim can be useful
but then when you look at beginner games
when they are putting their knights on
the side of the board it just doesn't
make any sense you know your knight is
better in the center than on the side in
general so you shouldn't put the knight
on the side but
yeah to something's not used to
analyzing advanced games like this
that you know several times that once
you said your reasoning out loud it made
sense that for now i see that as very
constipated for white to what for lack
of
analytical term and that black being
kind of behind a lot of walls like in
other words the black really seems well
defended to me yeah and that um it's not
active he's not on the attack because
his pieces are he's all behind
um the fourth his fourth rank
yet um he's kind of unassailable which
eventually wins the game in a lot of
games and you're using nope because he
has this weakness that he doesn't
understand
yeah um i mean if if white didn't have
this active plan of pushing over here on
on the the queen side then i like black
might be okay like if black if i just
doesn't see this idea or something then
black might be doing all right but uh
you said that black doesn't have really
any weaknesses but i mean this this pawn
is is big this is what sort of enables
this plan having this d6 pawn be weak
like this
um and aside from that b7 is definitely
a weakness as well uh and it's one that
we're targeting so
uh while we didn't ever win the b7 pawn
in this game again we're really keeping
a major piece at bay here uh because of
this
yeah you're weakness that
because it's again what you said earlier
it's tying up that rook that cannot do
anything it can't get off that ring
because it has that v
seven pawn to defend because that would
be a fatal attack yeah
um and so it's it's committing a piece
100 to one stupid pawn and even though
it seems like
no big deal it's a big deal yeah i mean
that that's what weaknesses are are
about in in high level play it's not
necessarily about winning them outright
but it's about how your opponent has to
make concessions to
to avoid losing uh losing their weak
pawns
um so yeah very impressive game from
lavon all the more impressive when you
realize that he's he does this coming
off of a loss with the black pieces you
know you start your day with the loss
it's easy to let it kind of spiral but
levon comes back and plays this game so
fun stuff
now i do want to move on uh make sure we
have enough time to look at this game as
well
there's really one major point i want to
highlight in this game that uh
that is the reason why i think anish
geary lost and levon actually talked to
me a little bit about it after the game
and that's you know i didn't come to
this magical understanding on my own um
so i had some help on this one
but uh this game is the game directly
after the one that we just witnessed so
anish has white again the the match
score is now level at one to one so he
wants to come out and take the lead back
so we get e4 e5
and it's the the petrov this time around
we get an early d4
in the petrov so this is going to be
very concrete lines here
because black is taking in the center
and things are going to open up really
really quickly
we get bishop to d3
knight to c6 so this is a bit of a
surprise if you haven't seen the idea
before but white is actually not
going to be better after bishop takes e4
because we expand out with d5
the bishop is trapped so it has to come
back to d3 and then we go e4 and this is
a simple fork so
a nice tactical idea that helps justify
the opening here so instead of taking
the knight white as actually going to
take on e5 here
this time with the knight we get knight
takes e5 d takes e5
knight c5 bishop c4
um and then i really like the idea that
aronian comes up with here so
uh for the moment it looks like whites
might uh
might have something going on here right
we have this strong e5 pawn
and it is definitely a challenging
black's development here so
there are a couple ways to break free
but i want to see what you guys can come
up with
what's black's next move yeah how do we
break how do we finish development here
because with this e5 upon it it can be a
little bit uncomfortable
uh my
intuition which i'm sure is wrong is
the d-pawn so that you can get the black
bishop out
yeah so d6 is is a normal idea um and
and the point now is just that this pawn
it might be good over here on e5 but
it's a little bit too far advanced for
white to keep total track of it
um
and for example black would be happy if
we got takes on d6 and takes on d6
activating kind of for free because
white spent this turn taking
so after d6 white is going to try and
potentially give up this pawn or just
make threats right away continue the
tactical idea with something like queen
f3
or or even castles
and i mean you're gonna have a game uh
if black plays well then black should be
able to finish development by by
challenging the pawn uh but lavon
actually comes up with a different idea
which is not to challenge the pawn by
playing d6
but to sort of
force this trade
uh by way of playing c6 so how does this
make sense
uh well after castles lavon is now going
to play this move d5
and the point is we use the pawn to
support the d5 square and again we are
happy if e takes d6 is played because we
develop our bishop for free
and so this is sort of a way of inducing
white to to capture our pawn if we play
d6
you know white might not be tempted
enough to actually capture on d6 and
allow us to develop so by playing c6 and
d5
now our d-pawn is so strong that uh it's
in white's best interest to actually
take it and allow us to develop with
bishop d6 so
does his wife know does white see that
it's at the end of the game playing the
black bishop developed for free by doing
this yeah um
what you know that we're always assuming
our opponent sees the ideas and are
playing the best moves um so d6 is
essentially kind of hoping okay i hope
that white takes on d6 and i can take
back with the bishop uh so what lavon is
doing is he's saying
look at how strong my pawn on d5 is if
you don't take it you're gonna regret it
uh because you have to move your bishop
away and now i can i can even capture
your bishop potentially or you go back
to a pretty bad square like e2
and then this pawn has such good control
over the center that it doesn't matter
that you have your pawn on e5
so that that's lavon's idea is you play
d5 make your center so strong that that
white kind of has to take it
so in the game geary does take we get
bishop takes them d6
um rook to e1 check
and now bishop to e6
uh
and
you know at first everything seems to be
uh all normal here we just developed our
pieces pretty normally but lavon after
the game mentioned a really interesting
line uh that's i i just didn't even
think about as uh at my level just
spectating the game
so here uh try and find what looks like
it might be a winning tactic for white
looks like white might have something
really interesting here to uh to
challenge black's position
the white has a series of attacks that
will give it superior position but not
material
well no it looks like white
should be able to win material here
right or at least
i mean
very clearly be better unless black has
some kind of counter punch which as
we'll see levon obviously does
so queen h5 isn't quite enough uh
because if if you don't make a serious
threat i'm gonna castle and once i
castle i think i'm i'm safe
if you take
i'll take
yeah
so the night on c5 is is crucial
so what's white's next move
so keep in mind the knight on c5 is
crucial
for black
we need this knight to defend otherwise
bishop takes e6 is strong
yeah just b4 um and this is the the type
of tactic that's uh is actually easy to
miss because
you see b4 you see the super unnatural
pawn structure
and you see all the weak dark squares
and you're like ah i would never even
consider b4
i mean obviously though if you're
ripping open the center with black's
king still there it's worth considering
um
so b4 uh it turns out that lavonne has a
very complicated way to maintain the
balance and a little bit of an easier
way so
uh what is the counter punch what is the
counter punch here
ah not necessarily this this isn't going
to be enough if if we allow bishop take
c6 like this we are going to be in for
for quite a lot of hurt quite a lot we i
actually we're just losing our bishop
immediately uh
white's going to take it no matter what
uh and if bishop b7 queen h5 and stuff
so moving the knight's not good enough
queen f6
okay queen f6
you're threatening
i i think in this case though i i might
not care um i could take on c5 i could
actually take on d6 as well and you
might you know this you might regret
having your queen on the a1 square when
i play bishop takes e6 and rook takes e6
and queen takes d6 in other words
the power of this idea isn't necessarily
to you know win a pawn or something it's
to you know expose this black king
so castles does actually lose a piece
though um it feels like after pawn takes
knight we would get our piece back with
the bishop's bishop but now this pawn is
again attacking a second piece
um
so
after b4
and actually no one in the chat has this
idea either oh okay somebody's found it
somebody's found it
um but yeah the the crazy idea that
lavon comes up with is actually to
put more of his pieces in danger with
bishop e5
so the point now is that we've
definitely nullified a lot of the attack
if we trade the queens
and materially
black is going to be able to
regain any pieces he he loses here so
uh what's wrong with bishop e5 well it
looks like the bishop is attacked by a
rook obviously white can't take
immediately otherwise he loses the queen
so queen takes d8 is a natural first
thought
so takes
takes now rook takes e5 is definitely
our main line
um this isn't quite backrank checkmate
because we have bishop f1
and then if black tries to
regain the peace with rook takes c1
white is going to keep an extra piece
for the moment with pawn takes on
c5
but that's not the end of the line
for the moment white is up on knights
but here black is still going to be able
to to regain the piece believe it or not
with king to d7 or king to d8 and the
point now
is that bishop to c4 is coming and this
is black's idea
to regain his material if you play rook
e4 trying to stop me i think i can just
go bishop d5
and you have to decide now if you want
to stop me from coming to c4 or control
the file if you control the file
i win my piece back
if you try to stop me i'm actually going
to bring in the rook
and i will still
be regaining my piece with with a little
extra here i think so really really
complicated tactics going on that i mean
i didn't even consider like b4 didn't
even cross my mind here
um
but the easier way to do it is actually
with bishop e7 it's the exact same idea
but it turns out this threat to the rook
on a1 is a little unnecessary um
and just to show how this would go
um takes takes takes takes is is fine
for black
so bishop e6 a more controversial move
than you might expect
so in the game gary of course is like
yeah i'm not playing b4 just takes on e6
knight takes on e6
but now black is not going to have any
problems we have a symmetrical pawn
structure if anything black is the one
that's more developed with the minor
pieces
and after we get castled
um black has no problems here the
position is just symmetrical black is
perfectly active and uh we have a level
game
so i don't want to spend too much time
here in the middle game because i think
it's there's not too much to talk about
both players just stay active
um we get some trades
uh here by the way
uh okay i guess you just don't ever have
time to uh to take on a7 because we're
hitting the rook
um so rookie two now a6 to defend the
pawn
notably levon ironian puts the pawns on
light squares against the dark squared
bishop an idea hopefully you've heard of
before just to keep them safe
we get bishop a5
and now levon tries to double on the d
file anish of course is going to stop
him
so takes takes
rick d8
knight out and bishop back to c7
so again in end games like these uh it
is really really useful to just have
your pieces on solid squares it might
look like they're not really threatening
weaknesses or anything
but they're nice and and solid they're
not going to be pushed around and
bullied in the tactics this bishop is
yeah uh this knight is very strong here
on e6 meaning it's defended by a pawn
you know white is not really thinking a
f4 f5 is is the way to win the game if
anything it weakens the second rank in
in this diagonal
and so it's a solid piece there's not
going to be any tactics against it
meanwhile this bishop is
kind of hidden behind the pawns but
still very active controlling a lot of
these squares and so levon is just
keeping things solid you know not
overpressing not trying too hard to win
the game just keeping his pieces uh
active and solid
uh geary now continues out with a4 we
get king f8 bringing the king in for the
end game king f1 king e7 king e2
now rook d5 and now white does play this
move f4 so gaining some space
on the king's side now that the king has
been uh been centralized so i i don't
really have problems with anything
either player has done so far
but we're gonna see a big mistake here
in a minute so g6 is perfectly fine just
to try and slow down any ideas
knight to d2 h5 just gaining his own
space on the king's side now
knight bout knight out to f3
pawn to a5
and now pawn to b4
so
this a5 move might seem a little
counterintuitive to put the pawn on a
dark square but lavon is hoping to
constrain a little bit uh white's play
on the queen's side in the meantime
notably he just hasn't touched these
pieces they all stand very very well
they're centralized they control
important squares and there's no reason
to kind of move them around
instead he spends his time improving his
pawn structure now that he's improved
his pieces
so a5 and then again this move b4 is is
the big idea i want to talk about here
so i don't like this move
and i don't like it because
lavanderonian told me it was bad
but let's try and understand why so why
is b4
so wrong
and to give you a hint to get you
thinking along the right tracks it has
to do with what i've been talking about
having really stable pieces
i see someone differently again with my
understanding of the game that
the game's not over there you're
allocating resources to it we're away
from the king trying to kill the black
game everything else is a waste of time
so there's not a clear attack there
because the bishop
and the rope are both defending
um
yeah well okay uh just to get you kind
of in the head of a niche gary here he
he's hoping to uh attack on on the queen
side here maybe win one of these pawns
maybe just get a pass pawn and try to
make some threats by uh trying to push
some pawns it's a not not an uncommon
end game idea
uh but it does come with a pretty big
downside here and it turns out that that
downside is is what's going to be
white's undoing in this game
would it be that
it's going to be a 2vs2 versus 2 and
there is
um white has an apon which is generally
weak weaker than the more centralized
bonds um
so i guess you're saying if if this
trade were to occur right
you're just saying a c pawn here is
better than the a pawn
um so kind of yes and no um
so it turns out a takes b4 is what was
played in the game and it's the reason
why lavon thinks this is a bad move
but it's not necessarily because the a
pawn is weak or anything um but the the
fact that you mentioned
is actually going to be really true here
the c pawns can influence the center of
the board and in this case that is going
to be really really important because in
the current position it looks like all
of black's pieces are really stable but
white does have an option to maybe one
day throw in a move c4 i'm not saying
it's a good move now because it really
weakens some dark squares
but uh we have to keep in mind that our
rook isn't going to live here forever if
we ever are relying on our rook to be on
d5 it could be pushed away potentially
by this move c4 and so what levon says
is that after b4 a takes c takes now
this idea of c4 is never going to be
there and so our rook on d5 is not going
to be pushed away with tempo
and because of that i think that gives
levon a lot more freedom to
do what he does on the king's side
because he can rely on this rook to be
so supportive on d5 supporting
this fifth rank
now he's able to to launch his pawns
forward on the king's side so let's just
see what happens in the game really
quickly
we get f6 g5
and then he continues out even with h4
and h3 and g4 gaining all this space on
the king's side and then we'll see that
he actually finds some tactics to use
this space to win the game when you have
pawns so far advanced there tends to be
tactics with you threatening to clean
them
so let's let's do this a little bit more
slowly and in particular let's look at
this move right here so g5 so imagine
this move if white still had a pawn on
c3 then you can imagine something like
c4 happens our rook is very very uh
short on squares
where it stands and our our control over
this g5 pawn is going to be a lot less
uh certain for example let's even go and
move further takes takes
um bishop c3 h4
if you can imagine uh you know upon
landing on c4 here erica is going to get
kicked all over the board and i'm not so
sure levon would be able to hold on to
these super far advanced pawns on on the
king's side you know
uh it might be better to actually look
uh let's say white played something like
b3 here rather than b4 and we we
followed along the exact same path g5
takes takes c4
and
you do have this move rick f5 but but
now
you know with your rook sort of uh
undefended like this
your pawns are just are gonna be a lot a
lot weaker
uh and just to to continue align here
let's say uh
i'm sorry
well it they're attached twice and
defended twice
um but it's two on two that's why that's
where i get confused yeah well i mean
it's just by virtue of pushing them
forward you know the further forward you
go the the more control white's going to
have over over the squares
um so let's say for example like rook f1
here
and you try something like uh
like like this move again you know maybe
i can even consider taking and because
your rook is is not as solid as before
uh i can still play uh
some tactical ideas like this
but
okay i'm sort of sort of playing a
little bit loose here i'm gonna cheat
because we're running out of time and i
don't have time to think these through
these things all the way through
um so yeah with our rook being pushed
away maybe just some rerouting is is
going to be good and if we try to follow
along the same lines
uh now ideas like g4 could could
potentially push our our pieces all the
way back you know something like h3 here
for example and again now rook f1 our
rook is just unstable and so its defense
of these pawns on the king side is going
to be a little bit tougher for example
if we have to trade and play g4
now uh white is in much better position
to challenge these pawns see it's it's
so much easier when the engine tells me
how to attack them but um this is the
point this is the point right and you
can compare this with the main line
where after something like h3 this is
where uh we ran into all those problems
with our rick getting pushed around and
white attacking the pawns now there's
just no way to do that for for white our
rook is solid it's steady here and it
can't be pushed away
so in the game we get g4 knight g5
knight e4
and eventually using all this extra
space we get this tactic with bishop
takes g3 now you cannot take because i
can push
and i will be queening shortly if you
try something like knight to uh
to f2 to defense i can okay i can play
all sorts of things uh simplest is
probably to do this
okay if you go to f1 i actually queen so
you go this way i take and then i'm
still going to clean
so levon goes on to win the game there's
more tactics here gary plays knight c5
we get this strange little tactic where
the knight's captured but we have the
fork
and then with the extra pawn
uh lavon is able to to win the game
actually he does so uh simply with
checkmate here rogue g2 would be
checkmate and very difficult to stop
rick g1 we take and you actually just
run out of moves here you have to move
the rook away
and this is checkmate
so lavon beats anish geary today and
these two very very instructive games
um gary resigned here after rook to e2
so it it's just meeting three not much
to be done for an hq
uh okay so we are a little bit over time
here so i am gonna call it with that
thank you all so much for joining me
here on the road to 2000 up next alex
yermalinsky is going to be teaching a
lecture which i think i saw him walking
around back there somewhere
so he'll be in the hot seat next please
stay tuned for that lecture and i think
ben will link it in the chat for the
internet viewers
as always thank you very much for
watching my name is caleb denby and i
will see you next time
[Music]
you